et Thierry Thierry Ardisson comment il
fait il fait tout en noir il sort en
noir et bouffon noir il baise en noir
comment il prouve qu'il s'est changé
[Applaudissements]
pas trop quand même
tout le monde aime tout le monde connaît
c'est ton ami
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on commence par une très bonne
nouvelle Thierry une fois n'est pas
coutume Gilbert Montagné va recouvrer la
vue si l'opération réussit une cellule
psychologique devra expliquer aux
chanteurs qui l'a soutenu Nicolas
Sarkozy et non pas Ségolène Royal à la
présidentielle
politique Roselyne Bachelot déconseille
le téléphone pour les enfants c'est con
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il
téléphonait énormément le petit
comme ça
aux Émirats Nicolas a reçu une médaille
de la part du chèque Khalifa j'espère
qu'il a pu en avoir une deuxième bah oui
une pour Carla et l'autre pour Cécilia
encore
[Applaudissements]
social 11 employés de la Poste
obtiennent que le temps passé à revêtir
leur tenue soit indemnisée si on paye
les gens quand ils s'habillent pour
travailler les maîtres nageurs et les
actrices porno vont gueuler et Thierry
Thierry Ardisson comment il fait il fait
tout en noir il sort en noir et bouffe
en noir il baise en noir comment il
prouve qu'il s'est changé
exactement
500000 comment ils s'appelait en même
temps il y a un t-shirt trois minutes
fait divers deux personnes écrasées par
des arbres pas d'inquiétude des arbres
seront replantés
[Musique]
de la cocaïne stockée dans des boîtes de
haricots attention les haricots faisant
péter c'est tout votre entourage
cette blague fait partie du spectacle de
Jean-Marie Bigard présenté en
exclusivité à Benoît XVI
société un nouveau numéro pour signaler
les maltraitances aux personnes âgées le
à retenir on aurait pu les secourir à
temps
Chantal Goya revient sur scène à 62 ans
et ben voilà voilà quand ce sont les
vieux qui nous maltraitent il y a aucun
numéro pour gueuler
[Musique]
opération piège jaune c'est reparti
bonne pioche pour David Douillet puisque
cette année dans le TGV Piaggio Carla
Bruni remplacera Bernadette Chirac
[Applaudissements]
le
dans Gala Nikos déclare les paillettes
la lumière c'est pour mieux me cacher
oui alors
il l'a dit
alors une paillette suffit pour le
cacher c'est certain la lumière chez lui
elle était temps depuis longtemps
Jean Sarkozy craque pour l'héritière
d'artiste alors c'est pas un contrat de
mariage c'est un contrat de confiance
et si tu es pas satisfait en 24 heures
chrono avec la change
Pierre Sarkozy producteur de rap c'est
ça pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas Stevie
chroniqueur littéraire sur France
Culture pendant qu'on y est pourquoi pas
Mimie Mathy championne de basket Carly
en slim et Jerry chez Dior et pourquoi
pas si on pousse le bouchon un président
de la République qui se Mac à Disney
avec un mannequin foire été
[Applaudissements]
alors attention soyez vigilant Thierry
frayeur frayeur à France Télévisions
Anna aperçu deux Patrick de Carolis
ça fait beaucoup pour une seule chaîne
et on termine
[Musique]
on termine avec la photo de la semaine
dans match la maman de Carla Bruni pose
dans son salon en culotte et en soutif
c'est une vraie photo et
on attend évidemment avec impatience le
prochain numéro de match peut-être la
grand-mère de Carla en guêpière en
string les paris sont ouverts merci et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu